beneath the mother spear deep within the  forest of Maratha  ikot days witches worked there strange  magic under the cover of night when  howard and matthew alton bring you a new  or a fantasy graphic novel a young girl  born into a noble family but also into  the hands of a manipulative coven with  darkness as their cover the witches  countered their dark works and brought  forth Tatia  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  we'll table yummy there's two men to  their will or have they unknowingly  through their own hubris Unleashed  something upon the world which will  finally fracture the delicate balance  that they have tried desperately for  centuries to maintain  [Music]  Dahlia book1 exordium  now available for pre-sale on IndieGoGo